all these months at sea
we are you looking for that this place
my father gave His life has told you
what it is
Declaration of Independence I died a
true American
this ain't Michigan it's gold country I
mean have a competition no one else to
succeed I grew up in a tough
neighborhood sold everything captured if
anybody would buy I'm not saying that
the army available for you all I'm
saying is that you get out of exactly
what Jordan
goodnight
thank you for standing up the Coalition
on West boomer speaking that easy
situation
control
this Wars long
my brothers
shall we play a game do you really make
two and half million last year you've
tested positive for HIV
it's gonna be considerable turmoil in
markets for the foreseeable future
Wall Street is exactly what got us into
this mess I work for this company for 17
years I said Wars and invented the
future and talking about taking the
entire social experience of college and
putting it online I believe we live in a
great country
you